so with the recent passing of Mohammed
Ali who's known as the greatest boxer of
all time I decided to dedicate this
episode to him because I think everybody
has a Muhammad Ali story every single
person I know somehow some way has an
Ali story as to watching my kids another
when I was a kid I was watching I was to
watch it everyone's got some kind of a
story without leave and to me I have my
own but I'm gonna talk about you know 10
lessons we can all learn as
entrepreneurs from Muhammad Ali and one
by one by one I'll explain each of them
to you under why say that let me start
off with the first one the first one is
standing up for your beliefs you know
this is a man that has certain values
and principles that he stood up for and
it was real principles that he stood up
for and was very vocal about it and
everybody knew by didn't matter what it
was he did not have a problem standing
up for his beliefs on what he but I
think I think too often one most of us
don't have real rock-solid beliefs that
we would give our life to let alone go
do prison time for it and this was a man
that was not willing to compromise
anything with the values and principles
that he had to himself even if it meant
him not being able to box for five years
and going and doing time he was able to
do that I think there's a lot of
entrepreneurs that can learn from that
to really ask the question of really
what are you running a business for what
are you really doing this business for
is it just about the money part cuz
that's pretty easy is it just about the
accolades and offend what are some real
core values and principles that you have
that you willing to fight for till the
very end
take a moment actually write those
things down and see if it gets a heart
beat see if it gets you to be getting
emotional cuz I got him very very
emotional when he had to compromise
certain things that he believed in so
that's the first thing we can all learn
from second thing take advantage of your
platform to make a difference in the
world he took advantage of his platform
which was boxing and he used that to
talk about his crusade to talk about why
I don't want to go to war because why
would I want to go and they kill other
kids and other people when I don't
believe in the war that's taking place
in the first place
he took his platform to talk about
issues that were taken at that time with
racism he took his platform to talk
about certain beliefs that he had in his
faith he took that platform to get
people to you know get in shape he took
you use this platform for a bigger
reason I think in in today's world
there's a lot of entrepreneurs that do
this right but a lot of times people are
too afraid to touch their platform for a
bigger cause because it may it hurt them
they're business wise this guy wasn't
afraid to do that because it was more
than just money to him it was about I
really want to make a difference in the
world and that's one of the reasons why
he was crowned Sports Illustrated I
think top 100 they put him as number one
the the sportsmanship of this century is
what he got recognized I want to say
1999 he's been on the cover of Sports
Illustrated I think 38 times and there's
a reason for that he uses platform for
bigger purposes number three be vocal
he was vocal he was very very vocal he
did not have a problem saying what was
on his mind even at times when it got
him in trouble he was a pretty vocal guy
to say what was on his mind and I was
one of the things that got him in
trouble and it was one of the things
that also got conversations to be had
that maybe nobody had the guts to bring
up and so people started talking about
on the media then the American people
started having these conversations at
the dinner table and and I know a lot of
times you'll get counsel and say well
don't be vocal or don't be this or
doumitt if it's if it's just to create
ruckus because you just want to kind of
say something else um lightweight
opinions things like that no but if it's
something that's true core value lots of
time that you put into it you want to be
vocal about it in a positive change not
negative breaking up positive change
then use your platform to do that and it
was very vocal about what he did number
four do not be afraid to get your ass
handed to you let me explain to what I
mean by that you know a lot of people
want to talk about may may well I'm the
greatest boxer of all time Mayweather
Mayweather Mayweather and if you look at
Ali's record I'm just gonna say this I
don't I haven't done my exact number I
want to say he lost five times how many
times an arleigh lose I wanna say he
lost there it is okay he lost five times
in his career think about this here is a
man who is the greatest boxer of all
time
he had 61 fights and he lost five times
he lost five times Ali the greatest
boxer of all time the reason why he has
by far so much more respect from the
boxing world than Mayweather is
Mayweather never fought people at their
peak and I know I have a lot of
Mayweather friends so I know many of
your comments on the bottom you would
may wear the fancy you don't know maybe
what is the greatest of all time that I
get it I mean I'm more of a Roy Jones
fan in the first place than I am
Mayweather but Ali was willing to fight
people and petition to get his butt
kicked you gotta have a certain level of
respect for that I think sometimes just
taken as an entrepreneur sometimes
people are afraid to take a risk because
what if I get my you know knocked out
what if I lose what if I do this he was
not afraid of getting knocked out he
just wanted to know am I the greatest
let me get in the ring and see what
happens oh my gosh this guy's punches
strong Joe Frazier who is this guy
holy moly he fought he fought George
Foreman at his peak if you look at for
men when he fought him listen
Foreman wasn't beating people Foreman
was hospitalizing people is what he was
doing there's a video when Foreman and
Ali got into a fight there's a video
where Foreman is hitting this back and
he did this in tension with the media to
see it and you literally see Ilya why
don't we put that picture in there you
literally see the the the dent he put in
this boxing back from the punch as he
was putting because he wanted to say
this is what I'm gonna do to your ribs
Ali this is what I'm gonna do to your
ribs and he hurt Ali even though he won
the fight all he won the fight there's
gotta be a respect for Ali to not be
afraid to get knocked out sometimes as
an entrepreneur you got to go to those
meetings you got to go meet with certain
people and get your butt handed to you
and not be afraid because you have to
pick yourself up and say man I'm really
not good yet I thought I was good but
I'm not I need to get better right now
immediately and that's what I lead that
the fifth point I would say that we can
learn from his and him as an
entrepreneur and she was extremely
competitive when I went to Kentucky
Derby I loved the Derby I think it's a
very good experience everybody needs to
go I've gone too many time multiple
times
it's a Louisville Kentucky and when you
go there Louisville Kentucky is known
for a couple different things they have
the Louisville Slugger
where they make the baseball bats and
its really cool cuz you see how they
make the bats and literally a block
maybe two blocks away from there is yo
Muhammad Ali Museum it's about a hundred
thousand square feet when you go to this
Muhammad Ali museum and at this museum
you'll learn a lot about Ali you'll
learn you see the Rolls Royce you see
the cars see all this other stuff and
you hear everybody what they said about
him how competitive this kid was how bad
he wanted to fight how much of a
competitor he was he just couldn't help
himself but who want to compete so bad
he just wanted to beat you and he wasn't
right all the time but truly he had such
a high level of competitive Drive that
that in itself was attractive and I
think as entrepreneurs when you look at
some of the guys that eventually ended
up crushing it at the very highest level
like a Larry Ellison or some of these
other guys you better believe these are
some of the most competitive people
you'll ever meet in your life
that happens in the world of
entrepreneur he'll on must go readers
but go study and go go study that guy
one of the most competitive people
you'll ever meet they want to compete
there is this notion that competition
isn't healthy because it gives you
anxiety and panic attack and all this
other stuff you know who's they've been
said by you know who says things like
that people who lost people who lost
people who lost and didn't work out
people who try to middle the business
and didn't work for them so they want to
tell everybody else competition is bad
because it's cover up their own failures
don't listen to that if you want to
chase something to do something very big
you got to learn from the people that
are absolute competitors you can learn
that from ollie number six watch your
association if you look at ollie we can
put some of the pictures here on who his
association was I mean it doesn't matter
whether it's Pele whether it's you know
he's sitting there as a Muslim having a
conversation with Billy Graham and Billy
Graham's wife and Billy Graham is
laughing here at a conversation they're
having he's he's been on shows he's had
talks with presidents all these sorts of
things but it associations was always
people that were ahead of him and it
always kept him sharper on what he was
doing so watching your association on
who it is
number seven haven't faith he was very
faithful to his faith I know faith is
probably of becoming less and less
popular because
most people out of people are going more
towards the agnostic route or atheist
and I don't believe and I'm this and I'm
dad I don't think a God could exist it's
totally fine I'm not here to change
anybody's disposition they're to me
anybody I've almost half study that's
done anything at a very very very very
very very high scale very high scale I'm
not talking about someone who did get
him what now I'm not talking I'm talking
highest of highest of levels they have a
certain faith in something bigger that's
gonna take care of them they have a
certain faith in something that has a
calling for them to do that's
supernatural to most that if you told it
to the average person the average person
was gonna laugh in their faces in
yourself you're so foolish you really
believe that nonsense you guys are such
weak people to believe that you would
believe something like that he had faith
and it was pretty vocal about his faith
and his faith played a very big role in
him doing what he did in his life he
gave a lot of credit to his faith so
faith was a big part of it as a business
owner I had a comment a couple weeks ago
on value team and somebody said
entrepreneurs don't need faith because
faith is not gonna get you out there you
know I will tell you I work 100 hours a
week and I work like it's up to me and I
pray like it's up to the man upstairs
and I've been praying for courage wisdom
tolerance understanding since I was an
atheist in September of 1997 when I
joined the army and I was an atheist for
the first 25 something years of my life
faith played a very big role in the
right things taking place in my life it
just kept happening and I felt like
somebody was around me and watching over
me and you can learn a lot from that
from a Leon how he is as well viii is
belief now let me tell you in the belief
on on how I'll describe belief that's
completely different than what you're
thinking about I'm not trying to say I
believe in himself there's a part where
he talks about how he was so afraid to
fight he was so afraid of getting he was
so he had this fear that he had to
convince himself and so he would talk
about how sometimes when he was I'm the
greatest I'm the greatest I'm the
greatest these were affirmations he kept
saying to himself because he didn't
believe he was the greatest under
greatest I'm the greatest I'm the
greatest you've ever seen you have no
idea what at that data and he would go
and he was going to his rants he was
psyching himself out to believe that he
was the greatest and and he eventually
believed that he was the greatest and
look what ends up happening to him he
ends up believing he's the greatest
and then everybody around the world
calls him the greatest boxer and many
many many many major credible
publication considered him the greatest
athlete of all time in the last hundred
years athlete of all time in the last
hundred years and it had to do a lot
with belief sometimes you want on a
diploma car I don't think they're gonna
buy for me I don't think I'm gonna do
this I don't know if I'm gonna get this
person want to go into business with me
I don't know why wouldn't they gonna go
into business for me I'm the greatest we
can do something very big with our lives
they're gonna go into business with us
watch what we're gonna do next five
years watch what we gonna go get watch
what it's boom boom boom boom boom man I
believe it now man other people are
believing now man now the industry is
talking about it man now we're validated
now that could take 5-10 years but you
gotta inject that self affirming belief
into you over and over and over again
where eventually this spirit this body
that you're with actually believes in
the words that are coming out of your
mouth that are becoming that are gonna
become a reality then you follow through
with it so here was a belief got number
nine a student one of the favorite
things I saw when I went to the museum
was there's a part of it you can shadow
box alley it's really really interesting
when you go into the ring and you're
shadowboxing alley very cool exercise to
do but when you go to a certain area and
you're going through and and they went
and interviewed everybody in this gym
that he used to go and train at 14 15
years old and what they said is Ali was
famous to going to the trainer as a
student and asking them who's the best
in different areas for instance he would
say hey trainer who's the best guy can
learn footwork from he would say that's
the guy right there
now that guy wasn't a good guy uppercut
wasn't a good at defense he wasn't good
at you know his jab he wasn't good at
training but he had to create footwork
so Ali would go to the guy who was the
best in foot working with Lawren
footwork from oh they didn't say hey
who's got the best training routine oh
it says nobody
training routine from this guy and he
will learn only training from this guy
hey who's the most disciplined or
disciplined that guy right there he
would go in the guy would say so before
if I had no sex that that I here's what
she did with the girl after a day before
you and it was a discipline part I
picked it up from there who's the best a
[ __ ] or that guy right there's got the
perfect job that he run here how do you
throw your jab
he went to everybody and he learned the
very best strength and boxing and he put
it all together and then Muhammad Ali
becomes - the greatest boxer of all time
and he was thinking like this from 14
years old
and I think as entrepreneurs you can
also use this in your space on what
you're doing you can go out there and
use it to find out who's the best
recruiter you know who's the best on
phone calls who's the best at attracting
talent who's the best at speaking from
stage that's duplicatable in a way that
you can also do it yourself who's the
best at negotiation who's the best that
finances who's the best at Operations
who's the best at systems who's the best
at scaling who's the best had known how
to race it doesn't matter what it is go
to people that are the best in different
areas of the business then take those
areas and apply to your business bone
you become the best in your space
whatever your space is now you're a part
of and the last one is somewhat
contradictory but it makes a whole lot
of sense is he was probably won this
best self-promoters of all time
entrepreneurs sometimes have a hard time
with self-promotion and I'll tell you
why and maybe this will make sense to
you on in the area of self-promotion so
what is self-promotion I'm the greatest
soft promotion I am the greatest so
think about that for a moment who's
gonna go around saying I'm the greatest
right that's kind of like saying I'm the
best real estate agent the local area
here and you know I would love to earn
your business and prove to you I'm the
greatest real estate agent in local area
who is this guy who talks like that I
consider myself one the best if not the
best loan officer in the area here I
consider myself the best in social media
one of the reason why Gary Vaynerchuk
does well on social media is not because
he's the best kind of social media is
because he's convinced the world he is
and so people keep going to him now let
me tell you he's my number one on social
media but I know a lot of people that
are very good but he's a great self
promoter he's an excellent south
motor bar cube is an excellent
self-promoter Donald Trump is an
excellent self promoter our president is
an excellent self promoter you go
through you go through history and find
that the hot Jordan was a good self
promoter these these athletes are great
self promoters entrepreneurs who do well
you'll eventually see a even Elon Musk
is a great self promoter he eventually
had to go into the pr world to get very
good in that area sometimes you need to
be a good soft promoter and but but the
part that it works for these guys when
they become great self promoters is they
also deliver so if you can you can there
are people that are very good in
self-promotion but they're not good in
the delivery part of it they become
hypocrites if you can master the art of
self-promotion and delivery you get st.
status in st. status is when everybody
says whatever that guy says you're going
to visit ma he's going to deliver
whatever they say it's gonna happen go
do business with them that's the right
type of person to be in business with
then that's running Saint status so the
self promotion part on what are you an
expert in get some street credit get
some you know pep in your step get some
you know confidence because you're
finally really learning how to do that
business and start start talking that
language a little bit and you'll start
seeing the difference this guy was not
afraid of self promoting himself as the
greatest boxer of all time and
eventually look what happens to him so
those are ten of my thoughts that I had
that we as entrepreneurs can learn a lot
from Muhammad Ali I'm a big Ollie fan
I've watched I think every single one of
his videos documentaries that are out
there I love the way he talks smack I
love the way he worked with his
opponents I love his fights when you go
to this museum you get to sit there and
watch his greatest fights whether it's
Norton Frazier Foreman and you're
sitting there as if you're in the ring
the way they have it set up but it's
always great to study these great ones
and it's unfortunate that we lost him at
74 years old well look what he did with
his 74 years of his life where he was an
underdog and ended up being somebody
that billions of people around the world
know about and why not you why not you
go out there and impact the world the
same way he did so with that being said
Ilya let's do it a hundred thousand subs
listen we got a goal a hundred thousand
subs on YouTube and we keep promoting
this because we
believe we believe this is by far the
best how to channel for entrepreneurs on
YouTube we believe that 100%
pound-for-pound we can't go against
anybody I don't believe anybody on
YouTube has a type of content that we
have on value tainment
so if you haven't subscribed we need you
to help us get 200,000 subs by August
31st of 2016 so please go click this
button right here and subscribe and get
your peers at Aulis entrepreneurs to
subscribe here as well and then on top
of that if you got any questions
comments about this please post your
comments on the bottom if you got any
Ollie's stories I always love to hear
all these stories comment your post your
comments on the bottom as well about
your Ollie's stories and if you're
watching this video on a complete
different website that embedded our
video can always go back to Patrick baby
calm bone and see a bunch of other
content and stay connected with me as
well thanks for watching everybody take
care bye bye